my father has always been my greatest
champion and my hero
congratulations on 50 years at the top
of the biz i love you dad
that was perfect you want to try one
more if it was perfect why would i want
one more
why don't we just do one more where
maybe you
really excel how you're feeling
yeah okay let's do it all right take
four what up pricklix it's me
dr i'm a ding dong doodle bug dip
my dad hates all of you how was that was
that good
to fight this takeover we keep close the
whole family
i swear to god that if you bring him
back i am walking
back to my office too salt
oh we're going for pgm pierce
good yeah let's do it i like it oh don't
be such a suck-up it's pathetic
what about you romulus i love it
but that's my honest opinion
so business is a competition i land the
deal
i kill kendall i'm crowned the king just
like in hamlet
if that happens in hamlin i occur the
thing i keep turning over my mind is
do i tell dad because if i drop the shoe
on ken now
he's crushed forever if kendall's going
rogue then
let him sooner or later it's going to
blow up in his face i'll love it when it
blows up and keep his face
how many died two guys lost thumbs and
there might be an arm they can't save
guess who just didn't kill anyone but
maybe only lost a couple of thumbs
i don't know this guy
[Music]
how are you uh you know i'm well
i'm very well i'm uh working real hard
you know
yeah yeah no uh not at all really maybe
who knows wow i don't have the attention
span like this is probably the most
interesting thing that's happened in my
whole life and i'm thinking about like
six other things can i suggest we all
take our shirts off
[Music]
should we get married
what you know well not that like an
equivalent of a thing like i abduct you
and force you to live with me
that's not equivalent anyway what to
think about i get it so let it
right i have this overwhelming urge to
either
knee someone in the vagina or spit on
the floor i suck at the whole corporate
flirt thing
metro poser beehives almond
milk napkins and chitchat
take another week on that report matilda
i've always thought of you and i mean
this in the best
possible way as a stone-cold
killer who says she would don't
know how to flirt
you guys are a team and uh when a team
is a team it can't actually physically
be beaten it's
impossible so go hard
go fast go you lovely bastards
roman you're a
i am not a i think you're a super
talented superstar and i
i love you
oh you're such a
you know how you're so efficient and
good at your job well thank you but also
sort of like invisible
like wallpaper like a boring old sort of
nothing like a competent kind of clever
filing cabinet that everyone seems
content to have around
oh i'm sorry am i interrupting something
would you like to give this man your
number
yeah i'd like to give him my number
why don't you ask for her number then
can i get your number
can you help me um
wait wait
and fetch another bottle please thank
you
no amount of antibacterial gel is gonna
be able to wipe the america off me what
do everyday people like what do you like
me yeah okay uh i enjoy spending time
with my nephews cooper and clark
i hike i have several high-end racing
drones oh my god stop
no offense but wow
good morning uh no uh correction it is
not a good morning for my pov because
you're here
and i hate you hey nice vest
womb scans it's so
puffy thank you roman was it stuffed
with your hopes and dreams
are you kidding about the presidential
thing no i'm still applying for the job
of president of the united states
oh good for you yeah do you do you think
that that's like a natural progression
from
never done nothing never to most
important job in the world
well like could you maybe get a little
experience at like a cvs
dad fired you man no he said it was just
gonna take a little longer
but he said that to be nice what i think
he meant to say was that he wished that
mom gave birth to a can opener
because at least then it would be useful
two drinks maximum
that's okay nobody here has any glaring
substance abuse issues that almost
brought down the company right
you got a haircut yeah i hate it bro
yeah when you're out there that's
hilarious your period just came on are
your nips hard
it must be because you are so out in the
cold ah
i'm thinking i throw three or four dozen
white shoe lawyers at you and see what
it would be like to actually
physically destroy someone dude
i don't know what happened but i'm sure
i can fix it
you oh jesus is like huge
in your face you're a piece of yeah
oh sorry about empty please nope
chivalry is not you know
[Music]
you